today on Battle Damage we have a very
serious challenge the most requested
test to date the indestructible
Nokia brick phone the Nokia 3000 series
of phones is by far one of the best
selling lines of all time legendarily
durable we're gonna see how the 35 10
model holds up there are three tests
here on battle damage drop from a normal
height drop really high and a final test
of extreme limits which for this phone
it's gonna have to be pretty extreme
we'll be capturing all the action in
slow-motion on our hand built camera rig
I don't think this bridge tests and I do
too much but let's see what happens with
action the back blew off that it's fine
it still turned on so it totally still
works now it's just faster and sleeker
you think it will stop functioning they
designed these phones it's like crumple
zones right it's like it's like a car
action it came apart in five totally
easy and snap together pieces haha fine
God and it's not even like loose or
anything it's like the internet was
right it popped back together it's
probably stronger now this phone is so
tough we're going to have to fight dirty
so we're gonna freeze it in liquid
nitrogen how much of this did we buy
enough the liquid will kill the phone
but structurally won't kill the phone
let's see how tough you are now phone
sick hole
action
the screen shattered the buttons flew
off so what do we think
instead baby
question mark bah-bah-bah what you guys
want us to battle test next leave a
comment down below with the hashtag
battle damage Eric it's reassembling
like a t-1000 liquid metal keep running
I just died